[Music]
samantha's with us in tampa florida hi
samantha how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh i'm an avid listener but very davish
so go easy on me
um we my husband is actively the air
force he's a pollen air force and his
commitment is up in
uh two years in this september
we just moved to the tampa area
and we are under contract with the house
with a new construction
i am very concerned because i feel like
we
were out of out of order of the baby
steps we do not have an emergency fund
the house has been delayed from july to
august now end of september the interest
rates have gone up and
i'm afraid
i don't know if we should try to back
out the contract and lose our 15 000
earnest money
or just
go through with it and
just
work extremely hard and hopefully murphy
doesn't move
well you've invited him in
i know
um
uh i'm a registered nurse but i don't
i'm not we just live here i'm not
working right now we have four small
kids our oldest is eight
um
yeah
so the the
the psalmist says the blessings of the
lord have no sorrow added to them
when i am doing something that has
sorrow added to it
i have to assume it's not from god
no that's me as a christian
and that's the way i look at stuff
and if i'm buying something that makes
me cry
then that's something i shouldn't be
buying in other words
i mean it's just stressful and with yeah
there's i didn't like the base had an
18-month wait list and
i guess we were just
i don't know afraid you got a house
you got house fever that's what should
happen you got
you got this
you got to buy a house and um then you
went bought a house and then you looked
down and went oh crap
and um you have now you you
you know you woke up and have a hangover
buyer's remorse we call it how long has
your husband been in
10 years how long have you been married
uh about 10 years you're tired aren't
you
i mean i'm just
like i said i'm i'm just
tired of nine four little kids babies
the way you said two years september
like you you know the date right you
know it yeah you're ready yeah buying
this house um
i don't understand the legalities like
you do dave but buying this house is not
gonna get you the security that you want
it to give you for the last next two
years
it's gonna be a curse it's gonna be a
mess
yeah so um
what i would do is uh
did you do a bunch of customization to
it
no it was just buy as is okay so it's um
have other houses in the neighborhood
sold
yes and it appraised like 50 000 over
than what we signed for it so maybe they
would like
to let you go
and give you your money back
why don't you talk to them
okay so you can make 50 000 more on this
house
and give me my money back or i can close
on it
and resell it and i'll make the 50 000.
but i'm willing to let you have it to
just not close on it if you give me my
money back
okay what do you want to bet they do
that
i got 50 000 reasons they might do that
yeah
that makes sense
yeah
but now you're feeling guilty about
doing that
yeah
yes you are
i heard it
i was just as clear it could be right
over the radio coming from what are you
worried about
well because everybody's everybody's
excited about the house but her
the kids are excited but i'm scared no
you should be you should be what's not
what is the house payment going to be
like 3 200 a month and what is your
take-home pay
my husband about
8 800 a month yeah
this is too much house
yeah
and you know it
and you're you're just standing up and
saying
you know there's a little kid part of me
on the cereal aisle that's throwing a
fit and wants fruit loops i love fruit
loops me too oh man bought a house
john this is not about you
and uh
[Laughter]
bought a house and now the grown-up
samantha's having to deal with that
kid's decisions
i make a lot of kid decisions but you're
having to deal with them
the grown-up mom of four
now has to look at this and go oh crap
this doesn't feel right
and samantha you know why it doesn't
feel right because it's not right
yeah a thirty two hundred dollar house
payment on an eight thousand dollar
income is not a blessing
you can feel it in your gut i would you
and your husband go over sit down talk
to the builder in person and say we can
close we will close and keep our word
but if you would like to refund us our
deposit we'll let you go make the extra
50 000 that this house is appraised for
because we really don't want it it's too
much house and we're scared and talk him
into letting you out of the deal and
giving your money back i'll bet you they
do